[Music]
our series of more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as americans
is far greater than what divides us this
morning we're introducing you to a long
time hair salon owner
who is giving someone else a chance to
run their own business
his name is pio imperati he opened his
salon in connecticut nearly 50 years ago
and he worked very hard to build up his
business but now as nikki betty
shows us he's selling it all for just
one dollar
nobody cuts here with scissors anymore
if you ask his customers pio empirati is
a local legend
yes yes now 79 his journey in the united
states began when he was 20. i left
italy
was not an easy task leaving people that
you
grew up with the opportunity
to make a living to build up a business
like i have
i don't think i could have done any
better you are the american dream
yes yes pio cut hair for years before he
met and married his wife carol
in 1972 they opened pio of italy hair
salon in new haven
but after almost 50 years of business
pio surprisingly sold the salon for just
one dollar i never told anybody
that i was going to sell the salon the
equipment
supply everything for a dollar nobody
knew that
actually to be honest with you i didn't
even know myself
it's happened in the moment i went like
that zero come on
you built this business all these years
and now you're just going to give away
so i says that's what i want i know what
i'm doing
over the years pio kept his eye out for
someone worthy of taking over his salon
that someone was stylist kathy mora did
you know she was interested in owning a
salon
i always bring it up when i interview
people i said
someday if you are interest this could
be
yours but kathy she jumped out
from the resident she's loyal honest
she's one of a kind maura has called the
salon home for 15 years
and the emperor's her second parents
what did that conversation look like
i was like in shock like who does that
and for this to happen to me there was a
lot of struggles
and ups and downs and
it means a lot yeah ah
for pio to give me something that he
built
i don't even know how to describe it
it's it's amazing
maura met pio at just 18 years old when
no one would hire her right out of
technical high school
how is it going horrible i applied
to like five different hair salons and
they were like
oh no we're looking for somebody with
more experience nobody
wanted to give me that opportunity and i
gave pio a call
and the rest of its history they take
you in
like they're a part of you like they've
known you forever
though no longer owner pio plans to
continue to work part-time
nothing's changed p.o is still here i'm
still here
the bill's just come to me now
mora says the salon will keep its name
pio of italy
a nod to the man who gave her a chance
when no one else would
why'd you give kathy your business for
essentially nothing
because she deserves i started from
zero and this country has given me an
opportunity
so let's give somebody else
an opportunity to
make a living and build themselves
in life for cbs this morning nikki
batiste new haven connecticut
i think pio of italy is in good hands
with kathy yes i do too
yeah i love the relationship between the
two of them and you've got to say
can't say enough about peel that he just
looked at her and thought okay
i think pio's got a pretty good deal
because he gets to keep working because
kathy says now the bills go to her
he gets the money in no more going on
correct but when you meet him and hear
him you can see why he did that
yeah and you can see why he did that for
her yeah and i love seeing how much it's
meant to her that's what was really
sweet